E aí
o Olá meu nome é Caroline Beto e eu
trabalho com dança Normalmente quando Me
apresento assim para as pessoas elas
falam Nossa que delícia jura ela se com
surpresas para trabalhar com arte que
não é tão como E aí logo em seguida Elas
costumam se colocar no meu lugar aí eu
escuto a para mim não dava sou muito
duro Não tenho corpo para isso Ou então
aí eu queria dançar só que eu nunca tive
como investir nisso meus pais nunca me
apoiaram então Eu segui outro caminho e
ainda já escutei Nossa eu levo jeito
para coisa em só que para homem é
complicado né Então muitos empecilhos
mas eu acredito que as pessoas que
colocam no meu lugar e pensando a
relação delas com a dança quando eu falo
da minha porque todo mundo percebe que a
dança EA arte pertence a todos
a dança movimento e o que é vida se não
estamos em constante movimento dança é
se expressar através do corpo se
comunicar através dele a gente tá todo
dia fazendo gesto se comunicando a gente
vive dançando e a dança está presente
desde os primórdios da humanidade já foi
usada para muitos fins e de diversas
maneiras Mas hoje ela carrega tabus
sobre quem pode dançar como herança de
padrões ainda é muito comum as pessoas
dizerem que dança coisa de mulher de
homossexual O que é preciso ter um
padrão de corpo para dançar e a dança é
muito elitizada ainda
é só pode estar participando daquele
universo quem tem condições de bancar
aquilo
é a minha relação com a dança aconteceu
em dois Ambientes diferentes
é um nas academias de dança onde eu fiz
aulas de balé dia Essa parte a dança
contemporânea danças acadêmicas e ao
mesmo tempo eu cresci dentro do projeto
social que minha mãe realiza desde antes
de eu nascer um grupo de danças urbanas
que aberto a qualquer um que quiser
participar eu era criança para mim tudo
é a dança foi só mais velha que eu
comecei a enxergar com os dois ambientes
eram muito diferentes nas academias eu
encontrei uma parte muito restrita da
sociedade maioria das vezes é um meninas
brancas de classe média e no projeto
social eu vi a dança acontecendo de uma
outra forma por causa do jeito que era
trabalhada e por causa das pessoas que
estavam ali participavam pessoas de
todas as classes sociais gêneros cores
sexualidades que poderiam através das
danças urbanas encontrar um estilo que
elas pudessem se encaixar que se
identificasse
e as danças urbanas atraem um leque de
possibilidades para as pessoas se
encontrarem
e contribui com o sentimento de família
de União que é construído ali isso tudo
causa um impacto muito grande na vida
dos integrantes então usam impacto na
minha vida Através disso e vem dessas
transformações que eu decidi que eu iria
levar dança como profissão e ser
professora para poder contribuir e levar
a dança para mais pessoas e poder ver
mais transformações Essa é apenas a
minha história mas hoje a gente vai ter
outras histórias demais integrantes do
mesmo projeto social que mostram como a
inclusão EA dança e projetos podem mudar
a vida das pessoas
oi oi meu nome é Denise tenho 24 anos e
faço parte do projeto há oito anos
quando eu entrei sim eu botei um muito
grande com o meu corpo eu não usava
shorts por ter vergonha das minhas
pernas por ser muito magra em uma
apresentação A coreógrafa tá decidiu que
o figurino iria ser todas as meninas de
shorts eu mandei mensagem para diretora
falando que eu não tava confortável
porque eu não costumava os lá ela
respeitou a minha dificuldade e permitir
que eu dançasse de calça no dia eu levei
a calça e o shorts e na hora da
apresentação eu me senti bem e decidi me
permitir eu usei um shorts percebi que
não era um monstro que eu imaginava
enquanto dançávamos pude perceber que
todos olhavam para a nossa dança e não
para o meu corpo a partir dali levei
isso para minha vida e hoje aceita o meu
corpo como ele é foi um processo de
muitos anos mas com o tempo fui
percebendo que o que importava não era
se eu te
o x ou Y mas o quanto eu me entregava na
dança Olá meu nome é Matheus Eu tenho 21
anos e eu mostrar a nossa começou desde
que era bem pequena Quando minha mãe me
cobrava para dançar nas festas eu sempre
tive muito gostou a dança mas eu nunca
fui atrás de aulas nem nada uma pequena
sempre tive condições para isso e ela
porque minha família preferia que eu
fizesse curso entre outras coisas
conheci o grupo em 2017 no começo fiquei
um pouco com o pé atrás e se eu ia ou
não mas no final acabei indo e ele me
arrependo de nada porque eu gostei muito
da Alegria e da energia do pessoal então
eu decidi entrar nesse barco todo esse
tempo que eu passei dançando aprendendo
e Conhecendo novos estilos através das
propostas feitas pelo grupo eu pude
realmente me conhecer e conhecer minha
ciência entendeu que realmente gostava
porque a dança é assim ela abre portas
para nos conhecemos mas ainda existe
muito preconceito dentro da sociedade
até mesmo dentro da dança por exemplo
homens que dançam balé por ser uma dança
mais Feminina e mulheres que dá
se você é uma dança masculina Mas além
da dança abre essas porta a gente
precisa de um lugar que nos acolher para
isso e o projeto foi isso para mim e foi
como uma família que permitiu aqui o
experimentar se sentem medo de ser
julgado é a dança e as Lá tem muito a
agregar a vida das pessoas tanto que
hoje em dia é meus opiniões minha forma
de expressar de agir minha sexualidade
foi tudo coisas que o projeto me ajudou
a descobrir e ao contrário de que muitas
pessoas pensam a dança as artes elas são
muito importantes é basta que existam
pessoas que vejo a sua importância para
treinar projetos similares possíveis
o Olá meu nome é Alan Eu tenho 20 anos
eu sou artista professor de dança graças
ao projeto social dentro do projeto eu
vivenciei as danças urbanas dos meus
oito até hoje embarcar no mercado de
trabalho da dança foi desafiador de
diferentes maneiras tanto da minha
relação pessoal com a minha dança com
meu corpo como eu desenvolvo isso tanto
quanto as relações que não depende de
mim e passam por diferentes espaços o
bullying na infância foi inevitável por
conta da minha cor do meu cabelo do meu
jeito mais afeminado por ele dentro do
grupo Eu sempre tive pessoas que me
aceitavam e que me respeitavam e que
sempre trataram assuntos como esse de
sexualidade gênero cor de maneira mais
natural a gente sempre teve rodas
debates conversas tão isso foi se
naturalizando conforme o crescimento a
minha adolescência e tem
o movimento dentro do grupo nós temos
diversas pessoas diferentes vivências e
isso faz com que a gente tem a cabeça
mais aberta para esses tipos de relações
como uma pessoa negra na dança e na arte
eu enfrentei e ainda enfrenta muitos
desafios porém eu sei que viver com a
verdade que a dança é em mim me faz
superar qualquer coisa
o Olá meu nome é Lucas eu tenho 21 anos
e faço parte do mesmo projeto fazem 8
anos eu perdi meus pais quando era muito
pequena e isso Acabou de perguntando
algumas relações minhas sociais assim
digamos e em questão de família também
eu não tinha um contexto familiar muito
presente algo que me desse aí entendeu o
que que era ser uma família que quer
fazer parte de uma família então quando
eu entrei no projeto eu conheci o
projeto eu comecei a entender qual que
era a esse rolê sabe qual que era o a
sensação de fazer parte de uma família
detalhe incluso em alguma coisa as
pessoas dentro do grupo a diretora os
meus irmãos a gente tinha uma roda de
conversa tem uma de conversa muito Ampla
e a gente fala sobre muita coisa tira
muitas dúvidas isso Acabou me dando uma
relação maior com cada um dali e eu
comecei a entender um pouco mais o que
querem fazer parte de uma família a
dança de rua desde o começo ela foi
composta por pessoas que
é chamado de Cruz esses grupos essas
frios São pessoas que se identificam e
tem um porquê de tá aí sabe elas têm
cada um uma diferença uma
individualidade e com isso ela se
completam e formam esse grupo esse senso
de comunidade e isso no grupo no no
projeto é passado muito bem e eu
consegui ali que eu conseguia entender o
que que eu precisava da onde Não deu
tava me metendo foi ali que eu consegui
entender o que que era ser parte de uma
família realmente é esse foi o ponto em
que eu falei Ok eu me sinto incluso em
algo isso foi tão impactante para mim
que eu comecei a entender muitas outras
coisas sobre mim mesmo sobre as minhas
perspectivas sociais perspectivas
profissionais e tanto que o grupo foi
tão influente que hoje em dia eu sou
professor na área de dança porque eu
acho que isso é uma das coisas que mais
me representa isso só entende dentro do
grupo dentro do grupo tem nessa vivência
com todo mundo essa relação de carinho
de amor de afeto de família realmente
Então essa relação para mim é algo único
e
é uma das melhores coisas que eu tenho
para mim então o grupo Os meus amigos
tudo que eu tenho aqui hoje eu devo a
eles e eles são muito importante um
e São muitos os exemplos mas hoje temos
aqui alguns que ajudam a mostrar como a
dança pode na verdade quebrar tabus e
que a arte vai muito além do treinamento
tá em questões pessoais e sociais de
cada um nos nossos encontros do projeto
social nós buscamos contribuir para que
cada integrante busque sua voz e
acredite seus potenciais arte da dança
ela coloca a gente em contato com nosso
corpo nossas limitações nossas
dificuldades aos poucos cada um vai
superando limites dentro da dança que
são transferidos para a vida isso tudo é
veículo para cada um busca sua autonomia
se um poder amento Sua inclusão na
sociedade o intuito nunca é tornar os
profissionais da dança apesar de alguns
encontrarem ali a sua vocação
e o intuito é levar o acesso a
oportunidade para a arte que é um
direito de todos
e hoje eu sou diretora e coreógrafa do
projeto porque eu encontro ali sentido
na minha profissão por poder
compartilhar o que eu sei nós que temos
o privilégio de poder estudar se formar
dentro da área que a gente quer a gente
tem um dever de compartilhar com quem
não tem assim a gente caminha junto como
sociedade a gente quebra Barreiras entre
as classes sociais a gente da
possibilidade de cada um tem a sua
liberdade de escolher fazer o que
realmente quer pode ser através da arte
pode ser através de esportes de jogos
Mas se a gente puder compartilhar a
gente impulsiona vidas nós somos apenas
um exemplo de como trabalhar com Arte ou
trabalhar com a inclusão oportunidade
com acesso muda vidas
e quem sabe se mais pessoas pudessem
fazer o que elas realmente querem
experenciar essas coisas as reações das
pessoas quando eu falo da dança seria
mais como as dos meus alunos aqui hoje
de pertencimento de sentimento de
família de aceitação de aumento da
autoestima de empoderamento identidade
de vocação e crescimento pessoal
relações naturais de impacto e Poderosas
que são direitos de cada uma